General Petraeus was on recently saying
that you know he he thinks that Russia
is in an absolute no-win situation there
and it's getting worse for them and I
tend to agree with that assessment that
Russia has clearly lost this war in a
conventional fight them mobilizing isn't
going to do anything near term and their
their troops just are not motivated for
understandable reasons they're not
defending Russian Homeland they're
invading another country and so the
situation is bad for food it's also
horrible for him on the home front bad
things are going on there so I think he
could now already be in a desperate
situation but he's not going to be
desperate he's a smart ruthless evil man
so he's not going to do something
desperate like launch a nuclear strike
on the United States that would be
incredibly stupid he is not stupid he's
brilliantly ruthless evil so what I
think he's far more likely to do is
release a clandestine bio attack on the
United States that's the smartest